the one thing i didn't take that i wish
that i had
is the sex panther
uh
cologne bottle from anchorman i would
have liked to have had that it's too
toxic and dangerous really to keep
inside probably best for all involved
that i don't have it
hi i'm paul rudd and i will be answering
fans questions from lad bible
what is your best party trick
um
i did this thing with my finger and i'd
take a phone and i could take a picture
of people and it looks like they're
standing in front of a
butt basically i could take your picture
and it and it will look like you're
standing in front of just a naked person
what is your favorite role you have
played to date i had a lot of fun
working on i love you man
that one was really a fun movie to do
and it was a fun role to play
awkward
uncomfortable comedy is
uh always fun to do
and uh probably comes a little too
naturally to me
at least the uh
awkward part
what is the best memento you have kept
from a movie or set well i have an
ant-man helmet which is pretty cool
i don't really take lots of things every
once in a while the one thing i didn't
take that i wish that i had
is the sex panther
cologne bottle from anchorman i would
have liked to have had that but
um
c'est la vie
it's too toxic and dangerous really to
keep inside probably best for all
involved that i don't have it
what is your go to karaoke song
well you know i don't really have a
go-to karaoke song i used to have a
go-to karaoke song
which was wichita lineman
um which is
not the crowd pleaser you would think it
would be
but uh i love that song i have now done
karaoke enough times
um that i like to try and do songs that
i've never done before i'd like to add a
little bit of danger into the mix
maybe a song that might be in another
language that i don't speak
who is the funniest actor you have ever
worked with
boy that is a that is a really great
question a very difficult question
because i've worked with some pretty
hilarious people but one of the funniest
actors that i've ever worked with
is paul giamatti
that guy makes me laugh so much and he
always does these really serious roles
but that guy is a goof and so funny what
song would you say best sums you up uh
i'm thinking i could answer it
ridiculously which is my obviously first
thought
because i was the first one that popped
into my mind was gloria by laura
branigan can you sing it uh no
it's in english i don't do songs that
are in english anymore what was your
biggest star struck moment and with who
ah oh
i mean i've had many i got to do a play
with paul newman he's just my all-time
favorite i could never ever get over the
fact that i was even
sharing
the same airspace
i i don't know where you go from there
but i also got to host saturday night
live with paul mccartney where do you go
from there
do you prefer playing the hero with the
villain what do you think
[Laughter]
i love playing the winner
maybe because i'm not one
or maybe because i am